[Musique]
c'est un parc au sol sur caillebotis
plastique donc on retrouve
l'alimentation
avec les mangeurs on retrouve les lignes
de pipette d'eau
mais après le concept qui est
complètement différent il y a pas de toi
on est un enclos avec des mezzanine
intérieurs et extérieurs on a une partie
jour une partie nuit
avec les petits terriers ils peuvent
s'abriter
[Musique]
on voit bien que dans les projets
d'installation on a beaucoup de jeunes
qui concrètement sont très attirés par
ce modèle là parce que comme je viens de
le dire c'est vrai que il y a vraiment
un contact et c'est ce qu'on sent un
petit peu dans la nouvelle génération
les éleveurs veulent être proches de
leurs animaux veulent se sentir bien
dans leur élevage et puis ils veulent
que les animaux se sentent bien
[Musique]
le but c'est vraiment d'anticiper
l'évolution de la législation européenne
qui va interdire demain c'est pas encore
faible mais l'élevage de d'animaux en
cage et donc c'est pouvoir promouvoir
toujours la viande de lapin et pouvoir
continuer à élever des lapins et aussi
aller recruter de nouveaux constatateurs
en disant vous avez un animal qui durant
sa période d'élevage ou de permet de
vivre le mieux possible et aussi de
recruter de nouveaux éleveurs demain sur
des nouveaux concepts comme ça
[Musique]